so Taylor Swift full
disclosure I obviously I mean I'm not
her demographic I don't listen to her
stuff I listen to good music I'm into
like old rock and roll heavy metal 70s
rock uh even
EDM um I pretty much listen to every
genre with the exception of classical
and Country um so I'm not a
fan a lot a lot of people are fans
though she's got uh let's see what her
fan base was I pulled it up on Instagram
here 28 80 million followers all right
well since I got that up I guess since I
have all my tabs up here in C I might as
well go through them as I pull them up
so the first thing you notice about this
tab over here is um
well there's a absence of Travis on it
it's it's all her um I know that the
romance is I think relatively new is
what most people would say um but uh
it's completely absent of uh Mr Kelsey
the important man in her life but she
has quite the pull 280 million follows
is nothing to sneeze at that is a lot of
U lot of people and um one of the
criticisms I think that have been made
of her reasonably anyway is um that
she's uh a bit of a scop we'll get into
that in a little bit um I put out a
tweet over here last not even last month
two months ago now we're in February
already um over
on X Twitter and uh it went it went
crazy a lot of people got pissed off at
me a lot of people loved it but anyway
so snapshot Taylor Swift she's 34
unmarried doesn't have any kids has well
at that time I saw 14 ex-boyfriends I'll
get to the real number in a bit which
ties into the red flag uh we'll talk
about this as we kind of deal with the
X's got a bunch of cats most popular
songss and these are just the ones that
popped off the page when I looked at her
um catalog of music Shake It Off look
what you made me do I Knew You Were
Trouble Bad Blood don't blame me and you
need to calm
down um she's been criticized for
singing a lot about her exes which there
are a lot of and um apparently she's not
had a good relationship with all of them
for the most part with the exceptional
one the guy from uh Twilight I can't
remember his name uh but she's but he's
the only one that she's remained uh
friendly with not as friends it doesn't
we couldn't find anything about her
meeting up with exes or men from her
past so either she doesn't or she's been
uh really good about covering that up
but the question I asked is do you
understand why Western I should have
corrected this and said Western liberal
women identify with her uh she's a
popular Avatar in that space very very
popular uh she's an avid supporter of uh
abortion right uh LGB you know the
alphabet rights um she was notably
absent from offering any opinion about
politics until about 2019 2020 I think
it was um where she started talking
about uh voting out Donald Trump and
um also encouraging her followers
to uh go and register to vote now the
controversies around these two they're
not as salacious as You' as you'd hope I
know people are looking people love red
meat you know they like they want the
red meat they want the Flaming red tits
right um the worst that we got here
is uh controversy with Kanye uh which
was insignificant you know Kanye is just
being Kanye being a dick when he clim
climbed up on the stage and uh
interrupted her um receiving the
award um let me see here what else
popped
up so she grew up in Nashville parents
had a Christmas tree farm both her
parents battled
cancer uh she's got
now you know people are looking for well
okay well what are the red flags I'll
get to that in a second she's got a very
good relationship with both her parents
so hat tip to her and you know to her
family for maintaining that because
usually one of the first things that
you'll see uh especially women start to
lean left left liberal is um you know
they make uh comments around supporting
uh Democrats hating Republicans um
supporting things like uh termination of
pregnancy abortion rights um lgbq you
know alphabet sort of community stuff um
interesting that came from Nashville of
all places because it's a more
conservative sort of town uh with
generally more conservative women um
yeah there's no other highlights on this
nope here so I'm not even going to
bother putting that one up here's
something which I found interesting um
because you know guys are like well do
you think Travis is getting into you
know he's he biting off more than he can
Cheo is she going to be a problem for
him later like what's going on because
Travis Kelce if you don't know who he is
he's a he's a tight end for the NFL
football team again I'm not a fan of
football either so I can't sit there and
watch other guys play games and stuff
like that but um he's world class at
what he does he's very very good at it
um we'll get into his character uh stuff
in a little bit one of the things he
said recently was that he was looking
for
breeder um he got called out on social
media for saying he was looking for a
breeder meaning mother stock essentially
and you know you know the fem Bots came
at him for it and started saying some
nasty things um let me just show you a
screenshot of her Taylor's parents
because this is where this isn't an over
red flag that I specifically mentioned
in the list of 21 in my book but it
should be noted that I think most guys
commonly will look at this
it's just known take a look at her mom
you know
before you take somebody on on a
long-term basis
um cuz eventually she's going to look
like her right she's going to age into
that c category usually I mean most
women have their kids from this era in
their you know 20s and very early 30s so
I'm assuming in 20 to 30 years or so uh
Taylor Swift is going to look a look a
little bit like Mom over here in fact
she has all the features eyes smile nose
everything uh doesn't look too much like
Dad but she's got all of Mom's features
for sure very very very strong
resemblance from the eyes but this
situation over here I mean if I if my
parents were still young enough and in
great health like her parents are I
would be embarrassed to have my parents
show up looking like that my parents
don't look like that and they're and
they're elderly now but um take a look
at a woman's mom that that's you know
that's a good sign of what you're going
to get in the future right right um
there's no get away from that I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clip's
from if you're newer to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out